amy santiago she's got seven brothers
so she's always trying to prove she's
tough careful that stuff's pretty hot
oh is it hmm
why are you taking so long to cook my
freaking oatmeal
she'll be okay how's amy doing
she paying enough attention to her
pelvic floor ignoring that
she is keeping a low profile just like
we discussed i'm really impressed with
you too
he disagreed with the best strategy but
talked it through like adults well the
key is trust
i trust her to stay out of danger and
she trusts me not to interfere oh my god
she just pushed figgis into the garbage
she's in danger i must interfere
what the hell do you think you're doing
huh showing my unborn baby how an ass
gets kicked
all right cortez time for your checkup
no thank you i feel
fine no you don't it's your uterus it's
gonna explode
come with me stand back everyone you're
all in the splash zone
oh this huge get a boot here we go
what the hell we agreed you weren't
gonna do that you disobeyed a direct
order from your handler yeah
i did because that order was crap i did
the right thing and it's insulting that
you don't see that
daddy hey the baby can hear you yelling
and it's upsetting him it's a fake baby
charles
i meant me the baby's a cover can be
hard to win our vet when you're on the
bench peralta
although i did start a new category
murderers we let go and look at that
you're winning have fun with your files
yeah you know what i will have fun with
my files have fun with your face
slam that was a slam
so what do you think um i don't love the
sash
but it's fine i'm just gonna get it what
that's the first one you tried on
i once saw you look at 54 different
accordion folders and not buy
any of them due to weak tabs i file hard
i need strong
tabs i just don't want to take up any
more time your break's not even a
quarter done
i'll stay another 10 minutes you'll stay
until i dismiss you irene
music now spin
all units attempt at 10 30 charlie
bodega on smith
purpose heading east on baltic it's us
we're on baltic
oh crap that was him
[Music]
[Music]
stay down damn sarge maybe i do like the
sash
hey cortez you're late for your
appointment quit touching me
i don't need checkups every two seconds
you dimple chin bro
wow you're so tough and i'm just a
beautiful intellectual
hey i love beating up doctors can i get
in here no
he's mine i'll back off i'm kicking for
two
his name is blair underwood
the man that's on the grocery store is
blair underwood hey ray
it's time for what detectives out of the
juggle
you to give me a promotion and a 40
raise
i've been carrying the squad for two
years and my back's getting tired
excuse me captain hey amy can i talk to
you for one second uh
you just did burn oh so good
so listen i don't think overconfident
amy is working out maybe you should go
back downstairs
maybe i should just have another drink
get ready america
here comes slicks okay that's
still working on that afternoon almond
i've been sucking on it so long it's
smooth
it's like sea glass you do you
i'll get that for you ames
[Music]
oops butterfeet sorry about that sorry
you bumbling son of a [ __ ] you just
ruined my life
i hope you get hit by a truck and a dog
takes a dump on your face nothing to see
here just a little hypoglycemic rage
move along i'm so sorry hitchcock that's
not me
i'm never like that that's okay it's my
fault i shouldn't bump your cashew
cashew it was an almond you idiot i hope
you drown in a tub
i hope you have an aneurysm after
aneurysm after aneurysm
charles what took so long i want to get
out of this suit before we take off
we're not going anywhere the flight is
booked and there's already a huge
standby line
what we have to get on that plane were
you stern amy you know i wasn't
i've got this holt's in danger and that
lady's in my way
never get between a teacher's pet or
teacher
okay vest lady i don't care what you
have to do today oh you sweet thing
you're pregnant
so pregnant what a miracle right
please give me special treatment i
ripped her a new one and guess what fell
out
two tickets to new york oh first class
upgrade
oh sir do you know why i love coming to
work because there's a bumper pool table
in the break room yes obviously i love
the bumper pool table but do you want to
know another reason why
you you've made me a better cop you've
made me a better person i've learned so
much from you
so you can't quit because i need you
[Music]
oh please how selfish that that little
speech you just gave it was all about
you and what you need how unbelievably
selfish
okay well i don't want to get mad right
now cause i know amy's worried about you
ah no screw that noise how dare you call
jake selfish he just wasted his entire
honeymoon trying to take care of you
while you wallowed in your
misery like a little baby that seems a
little harsh who does it
i don't give a hoot oh damn for the last
five years all i've done is give a hoot
about you
and what you think gave a hoot about you
as a boss gave a hoot about you as a
mentor i gave a hoot about you as a
friend
she gave so many hoots not anymore after
the way you've acted and what you just
said to jake
i don't give a what you think and i
really don't give a hoot if you decide
to quit the nypd so
do it i'm all out of hoots i'm hopeless
now what i want to say is jake coming
holly janeiro
you thought you could distract me with a
record deal please
i'm already represented by my mom god
you're a turd well this turd
is your best friend's future husband
doink hey wait no give that back to me
he's gaming on you
[Applause]
tell your mother i said i never loved
you and that your whole family is a
bunch of friggin
oh my god
[Music]
never have i ever slept with a guy
broken his heart hired him to play at my
wedding
stolen illegally binding contract from
him jumped on a bar dumped booze on
everyone falling off the bar probably
giving myself a concussion
and a permanent scar i have ever
[Applause]
i don't understand what is happening
allow
me to explain amy and i were ahead of
you the whole time
no you weren't part of this get back
over to the loser side
loser all right worth a shot so how'd
you pull it off well
it all started when i went to tell jake
how badly he hurt my feelings and he
yelled at my breasts
oh boy i am not going to come off well
in this story nope
remember when you set off the witch he
made captain holt flinch
which was weird since his door was
closed but not weird since he actually
heard it over a bug he planted at your
desk
it was in an old muffin that you never
threw in the trash that's why people
throw away garbage
how are we together anyway i tapped into
the bug's frequency
so i had ears on jake i needed to know
what holt was up to that's where
hitchcock came in
i masterminded the entire plan you did
one small thing and i had to explain it
to you like 45 times
he left a tiny crack in the blind so i
could read the captain's lips
sharon and your kids will distract jake
they'll be here at 9 30 sharp
my waffle xylophone on the cheese man
what
my lip reading is not flawless now that
i knew your plan it was simple to
disrupt
while scully gracefully moved the witch
i got into character
holt triggered the witch which brought
jake into the room and i threw the crown
in the trash can
exactly as i planned then i sent you all
here
placed an out of order sign on the
perfectly functional elevator
made you all walk up 31 flights of
stairs and vomit
twice actually it was four times if you
count all the stairwell stuff
you thought i was just holt's lackey and
you thought i was just jake's girlfriend
well i'm my own person capable of making
my own decisions
and i decided to humiliate you both
what are you looking at you got a
problem whoa
who the killer i just wanted to say good
job i'm beating the crap out of that
doctor
oh thanks i like you you got balls
maybe you should come work for me i
could use a bruiser on my crew
i'm not a bruiser i'm a psycho even
better
you